yeah it's weird for me because in my
background in the SEAL Teams you if any
possible way you have a buddy with you
as a matter of fact if you don't have a
buddy with you you're kind of getting in
trouble so you're always because you
know you can't watch your back you know
you you just can't right so you always
have someone with you so I've always
thought to myself man if I was a police
officer I'd really like to have a
partner
um well you're trained too I mean you're
trained to not let your your negative
emotions gonna get out of control yeah
uh I would definitely you know any the
same thing in the SEAL Teams I mean you
got to learn to de-escalate things and
and just being in a leadership position
you got to learn to de-escalate things
because someone comes in and they're mad
about something and if you're in a
leadership position and all you do is go
back at them it's see see they you know
Boston's plan sucks and you think oh
you're challenging me instead of saying
oh what sucks about the plan do you want
to make some adjustments to it like
that's what you do that's how you
de-escalate it you don't say well you
don't understand the whole problem I
dare you so right yeah